د الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بالدفاع
عن من سماهم المواطنين الروس في دونباس
ونوب روسيا واعتبر ذلك دفاعا عن روسيا جاء
ذلك في كلمه القاها بوتين بمناسبه مرور
عام على ضم بلاده جمهوريتي دونيتسك
ولوغانسك ومقاطع زبروجيا وخيروني ياتي ذلك
بالتزامن مع تجديد واشنطن الزامها بدعم
كيف في مواجهتها مع
[موسيقى]
موسكو
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تجديد موسكو
تمسكها بالاراضي الاوكرانيه التي ضمتها
خلال الحرب بالتزامن مع تاكيد واشنطن
التزامها بمواصله دعم كيف واعتبار ذلك
مصلحه امريكيه استراتيجيه ثم ما احتمالات
وفرص تحقيق اي من طرفي الصراع في اوكرانيا
تقدما استراتيجيا على ارض المعركه سواء
باستعاده كيف اراضيها او سيطره موسكو على
مناطق اوكرانيه اخرى ومن ثم نبحث في فرص
الحديث عن تسويه سلميه للصراع في ضوء
انخراط الغرب المتزايد فيه وما موقع
الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي سيطرت عليها
موسكو في اي جهود مستقبليه لتحقيق
ذلك
[موسيقى]
بموازاه تاكيد امريكي لالتزام بمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا في الحرب التي شنتها عليها روسيا
منذ نحو 600 يوم بل واعلان الاستعداد
لتوسيع ذلك الدعم كما ونوعا اذا لزم الامر
قد جدد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
تعهده بالدفاع عن الاراضي التي ضمتها
بلاده من اوكرانيا تصريحات بوتين جاءت في
كلمه للشعب الروسي في الذكرى السنويه
الاولى لما سماه عوده جمهوريتي دونيتسك
ولوغانسك الشعبيتين ومقاطعته زبروجيا وخير
سون الى روسيا الاتحاديه وقد اكد بوتين في
كلمته المسجله ان شعب روسيا دعم ما سماه
الاختيار الواضح والحر لسكان المناطق
الاربعه وهو ما يطرح تساؤلات بشان دور هذه
الخطوه في تعقيد الخلافات بين موسكو وكيف
والتاثير على فرص اي تسويه محتمله للصراع
[موسيقى]
بينهما
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو اولجا
كراسين ياك الاكاديميه والمحلله السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه ومن واشنطن الدكتور دونالد
جنسن الدبلوماسي الامريكي السابق في موسكو
ومن عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي معك اللواء فايز
الدويري
في ما يمكن تسميته بحوص في هذه الذكرى
الاولى لاستحواذ موسكو على كل هذه
المقاطعات في الاراضي الاكرانيه وتجديد
التاكيد بان هذه خطوه روسيه خالصه
لاستعاده وحق هذه الاماكن في تقرير مصيرها
كما قال الرئيس بوتين كمحص في الميدان
ماذا عن المؤشرات حتى
الان لا يعني المؤشرات يعني في البدايه
حتى قبل تصريح الرئيس بوتين علينا ان نعود
الى الاهداف الرئيسيه التي حددت في بدايه
الحرب من قبل الرئيس بوتين وكانت تتلخص في
التخلص من النازيه في بان اوكرانيا دوله
محايده ممنوع عليها ان تنضم الى اي
اتجاهات معاديه يجب ان تبقى الحديقه
الخلفيه للفضاء الروسي اذا الاهداف هي
التي تحدث بها في بدايه الحرب هي تعلو على
ما تحدث عليه في في هذا اليوم وبالتالي هل
روسيا ستكتفي بما حققته حتى هذه اللحظه
وتحتفظ به هذا شيء ام هل ستسعى الى تحقيق
الاهداف التي شنت من اجلها العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه فهذا شيء اخر لكن ل نتوقف
عندما يجري حتى هذه اللحظه الان توصيف
ميداني مختصر سريع كلا الجانبي للصراع
يتبنى الدفاع والهجوم في مناطق مختلفه
وحسب مقتضيات الوضع الراهن في تلك المناطق
تهاجم اوكرانيا في زبروجيا وفي دونس تهاجم
روسيا في منطقه شرق ليمان يقابل ذلك اصبح
هناك مسار موازي للعمليات العسكريه لان
العمليات العسكريه لدى الجانبين لا تستطيع
ولم تستطيع ان تحقق ما هو مطلوب منها
الهجوم الاوكراني تباطا جدا الهجوم الروسي
في شرق خاركيف متعثر وبالتالي القدرات
القتاليه لتحقيق انجازات اضافيه لدى
الجانبين اصبحت متواضعه ف فتم الذهاب الى
المسار الموازي استخدام الاشتباكات عن بعد
بالطائرات المسيره وغير ذلك هل يمكن الول
و المقاطعه لواء فايز هل يمكن القول من
ضمن الاماكن المسيطر عليها من قبل موسكو
حتى الان في الاار اراضي الاوكرانيه ان ما
يتعلق بزبرو جيا تحديدا المحطه
النوويه مفتاح مهم لاي خطوه تفاوضيه في
المستقبل يعني هذا موضوع فني وموضوع له
بعده من حيث الوكاله الدوليه لانه في
النهايه هو يعتبر يمثل قطعه جغرافيه من
مناطق متنازع عليها واذا ما تم السيطره
على منطقه زبروجيا من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه فهذه تلقائيا ستكون ضمن
الاراضي المستعاده هي لن تشكل ذلك الفارق
الجوهري من وجهه نظري لماذا لان العمليات
اطار العمليات العسكريه اوسع ولكن المشكله
اي مراقب ومحلل متابع يجد ان الاجهاد
الاجهاد يعاني منه منه طرفي النزاع القوات
الاوكرانيه متعثره في هجومها الجانب
الروسي بالامس تم توقيع دعوه لالتحاق 350
الف متطوع ليلتحقوا بما كان يعرف بقوات
فاغنر وتم توجيه دعوه التجنيد السنويه
الثانيه باجمالي في هذا العام هذه نقطه
مهمه لواء فايز هذه نقطه مهمه دعني اسال
عنها ضيفتي تفضل
تفضل يعني الان كيف اقرا هذه الرساله
اقراها في بعدين البعد الاول ان القدرات
القتاليه للجيش الروسي اصبحت لا اقول
واهنه ولكنها اضعفت ولكن هناك قرار سيادي
سياسي يصر على استكمال المعارك حتى تحقيق
الاهداف قد تبدو القراءتين متعارضتين ولكن
هذا هو الواقع ما ذكرته الان اسال عنه
ضيفتي من موسكو سيده اولجا كراسين ياك في
ظل اصرار الجانب اصرار موسكو تحديدا على
تس سميه هذه اوما يجري هذه الحرب في
اوكرانيا الى الان بانها عمليات خاصه ما
دلاله هذا الاصرار على هذا الاسم في ظل كل
هذه التطورات وعوده الرئيس الروسي للتاكيد
على انه ما جرى هو دفاع عن من سماهم
المواطنين
الروس نعم انت محق تماما
سيده اولج اسمعك
تفضلي للاسف فقدنا الاتصال بضيفتنا من
موسكو السيده اولجا كراسك لاذهب الى
واشنطن وضيفي الدكتور دونالد جنسن عن ما
يتعلق ب الحسابات الامريكيه واشنطن ايضا
مره اخرى وجددت التزامها بالدعم المطلق
لاوكرانيا حتى تستعيد كل اراضيها ماذا عن
هذا الالتزام والافق الزمن لهذا الالتزام
بالنظر لهذه المعطيات الان بعد مرور سنه
على استيلاء روسيا على كل هذه الاراضي او
ضم هذه الاراضي الى
روسيا شكرا على الاستضافه في البدايه
اعتقد اننا بحاجه الى توضيح حول ما نناقشه
روسيا لا تسيطر فعلا على كل هذه الاراضي
التي ضمتها الضم كان غير شرعي واوكرانيا
كانت تتقدم ولو بب هي تتقدم بطريقه منتظمه
نحو الجنوب
وجنوب الشرقي ونحو باخ موت اذا بوتين ك
سياساته يبني اذا الاوهام بناء على هذه
المعلومات المضلله والتي تشوه الواقع في
الحقيقه اوكرانيا تتقدم
ببطء كم سوف يستغرق تحرير الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله ليس واضحا لكن الروس
هم في موقع دفاعي و لدينا عدد من الالغام
و اذا التي وضعوها خلال فصل الشتاء لان
القوات الروسيه عاجزه عن الدفاع عن نفسها
بدون هذه الالغام وهذه الخنادق التي
حضرتها اما جوابا على السؤال هناك مؤشر
واضح بان الاداره الامريكيه سوف تستمر
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالدعم المالي والعسكري
هناك التزامات جديده
بال المساعدات العسكريه في الاسبع الاخيره
وستستمر
بنظري الحرب سوف تستمر لاشهر بعد وحتى
وصولا الى 2024 وربما ابعد من ذلك لكن
علينا ان لا ننسى ما يحصل على الارض وليس
فقط المعلومات المضلله التي نسمعها من على
الكريملين هل معنى ذلك انكم او دعم واشنطن
لاوكرانيا حتى الان يحقق
اهدافه دكتور
جونسون يجب ان لا ننسى ما هي هذه الاهداف
وهي ان تكون اوكرانيا مستقله وذات سياده
قادره على ان تقوم بصياغه سياستها
الخارجيه الخاصه بها وطبعا الشعب
الاوكراني
سواء كان يريد ان يدخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
او ان يدخل ح شمال الاطلسي هو اذا اراد ان
يتوجه نحو الغرب عليه هو ان يتمكن من ان
يقرر وليس ديكتاتور موسكو يجب ان يكون لد
حريات القرار دعم زيلنسكي في الحرب دعم
شعبي كبير بالرغم من كافه المصاعب وجرائم
الحرب التي ارتكبتها القوات الروسيه وكل
اعمال العنف ضد الاطفال والخطف وكل
الماساه التي
شهدناها على خطوط الدفاع اذا اوكرانيا
ملتزمه بمسار مستقل وهي تبقى ملتزمه به
بصياغات سياساتها الخارجيه الخاصه بها
وكذلك الماضي قدما نحو الغرب
والمؤسسات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه الغربيه
كيف يحصل ذلك كلنا نراقب عن كثب لكن لا شك
في ان هذا هو المسار الذي اختاروه وهذا ما
س يصلون اليه وهنا اسال ضيفتي من موسكو
سيده اولجا فيما كانت تعتقد بان موسكو حتى
الان
تحقق نسبه ما او تحقق جزءا ما من اهدافها
فيما سمته وتسميه حتى الان بالعمليه
الخاصه في
اوكرانيا ليس حقيقي اعتقد ان الاوضاع على
عكس ما تفضلت به
ان احتفالات بمرور عام منذ من ضم هذه
المناطق نحن نعتبر هذا ضم
للمواطنين الروس لان من وجهه نظر تاريخيه
روسيا الجديده اي زبروجيا وخرس ودم باس هي
مناطق تاريخيا كانت تعود ل الامبراطوريه
الروسيه ثم الى الاتحاد السوفيتي فمن هذه
وجهه النظر روسيا تقدم الكثير لهذه
المناطق والاهم انها تقوم بدمج هذه
المناطق بروسيا وهي تعتبر الان مناطق
روسيه فاذا ما نظرنا فقط للجبهات التي
تتقدم او تتاخر فهذا ليس هو ليس هو الاهم
بل الاهم هو الملايين الذين اصبحوا جزءا
من روسيا وهم مواطنين روس عادوا للوطن هذا
هو الاهم وهناك شيء اخر مهم جدا وهو انه
منذ عام
2014 الناطقين باللغه الروسيه في الدنباس
كان ينظر لهم من وجهه نظر
النظام في كيف على انهم
انفصاليين
و هنا طبعا لن يكن اي حديث عن مناطق
اوكرانيه وروسيا هنا تنجح في هذا دكتور
فائز دويري الان بالمعطيات
الحاليه موسكو تفعل كل شيء لكسب هذه الحرب
من يدعمون كيف قدموا كل اوراقهم من اجل ان
تحقق كيف انتصارا ايضا في هذه الحرب
وبالتالي كيف يبدو المشهد بين الطرفين في
ظل ان كل طرف يقدم كل ما لديه حتى يحقق
نصرا في هذه
الحرب يعني للاسف المؤشرات الميدانيه تشير
ان ال الوصف العام اقرب ما يكون بان الحرب
دخلت في مرحله حرب
الاستنزاف لا لا يقوى اي من الجانبين على
تحقيق الاهداف التي وضعها سواء الجانب
الاوكراني يعني لا يزال منذ حزيران يقاتل
في الخط الدفاعي الاول استعاده ما يقارب
220 الى 230 م من اصل 20,000 م مربع لا
يزال القتال يقاس نتائجه بالامتار فيما
المسافه الى الاهداف المتوسطه تقاس بعشرات
الكيلومترات على سبيل المثال الوصول الى
ملت اوبل عقده المواصلات التي ستقود الى
بيرديانسك او الى ما وراء بيرديانسك تبعد
85 م عن القوات الاوكرانيه بيرديانسك تبعد
125 م يقابل ذلك الجانب
الروسي اختار وضعيه الدفاع لانه يعلم
يقينا لو لم يقم ببناء خطه دفاعيه محكمه
وقياسا مع معركه خار كيف كان يمكن للقوات
الاوكرانيه باعتماد نظريات القتال الغربيه
ان تحقق اختراقات عميقه وتقلب الطاوله
فلجا الى الدفاع وبالتالي عندما نتحدث ان
كل الجانبين لا يملك القدره على الحسم ما
لم يحدث مفاجات غير متوقعه غير مرئيه ان
يتم مضاعفه نوعيات الاسلحه التي تقدم
والاعداد يعني الان الحديث عن 31 دبابه
ابرامز لن تقدم الكثير الحديث عن 80 طائره
اف 16 لن تقدم الكثير لكن اذا ما الغرب
استمر في الدعم فسيكون المخرج سياسي اؤكد
المخرج سياسي لكن ما يجري من قتال هو
لتقويه اوراق التفاوض على طاوله المفاوضات
النهائيه لان روسيا تستطيع تحقيق اهدافها
ما لم تحدث مفاجاه ولا اوكرانيا تستطيع
تحدي ما اهم الاوراق التي تملكها موسكو
اذا ما فتحنا بابا للتفاوض
باعتقادك
الان كان هناك تصريح لوزير الخارجيه قبل
اسبوع لافروف وتحدث بضباب لم تكن جملته
واضحه عندما اشار الى امكانيات التفاوض
واعتماد القاعده التي تم الانطلاق منها في
اتفاقيه عام
1991 باجراء تعديلات جوهريه اي بمعنى اخر
هل ستقبل روسيا باعطاء حكم ذاتي موسع ل
للوجان دونس ومقاطعات زبروجيا خرسون مع
استثناء شبه جزيره القرم هذه احد احد
الامور وبالتالي بما ان الجيش الروسي
يسيطر بما في القرم على 20 على حوا يعني
20% من انا عذرا يمكن قلت 20,000 لا هو
يسيطر على ما يزيد على 66000 يو 20% من
مساحه اوكرانيا بالتالي هو يستطيع ان
يفاوض بحكم الواقع الميداني ويقدم تنازلات
بالانسحاب مقابل تقديم تنازلات كبيره
اهمها الحكم الذاتي الموسع اهمها ان تبقى
على الحياد اهمها ان لا انضم الى النيتو
وقد يكون الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
ضمن تحديدات وشروط قيد البحث على الطاوله
طيب وهنا اسال ضيفتي واعود الى ضيفتي من
موسكو السيده اولجا اذا كانت كما ذكرت بان
موسكو او استعاده مواطنين روس الى حضن
روسيا ولكن الان مع مرور الايام في هذه
الحرب اصبح الطموح الاوكراني ليس فقط
استعاده الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولكن استعاده
شبه جزيره القرم الان روسيا تحت عقوبات
اقتصاديه خانقه هناك دعم لا محدود لكيف من
قبل حلفائه وبالتالي الى اي مدى تستطيع
موسكو ان تحقق اهدافها في ظل هذه
المعطيات حصلت على اهدافها في الوقت
الحالي واعتقد اننا سوف نستمر في استرداد
المزيد من المناطق مثل نيكولايف واوديسا و
خاركيف اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن القرم فاريد
ان اقول ان روسيا الامبراطوريه الروسيه
حارت ضد تركيا لمئات السنين لاجل القرم
علينا ان نقدر قدرات الدول ونحن نرى ان
اوكرانيا معتمده على الاسلحه الغربيه
تماما ليس لديها اي شيء محلي واذا ما
تخيلنا انه بعد الانتخابات الامريكيه اذا
قامت الاداره الجديده باتخاذ قرارات جديده
فقد تبقى اوكرانيا دون اي دعم اما روسيا
فهي معتمده على انفس على نفسها وهي تقوم
بتنميه قدراتها وانتاجها الاستراتيجي
ولدينا الدبابات والطائرات المحليه دون
اعتماد على احد اخر والعقوبات المفروضه
على روسيا كان لها تاثيرا ايجابيا لاننا
الان لدينا اعتماد داخلي على الذات
واستقلال وليس لدينا اي نقص لذلك في
هذه المقاييس
فليس لدى اوكرانيا اي قدرات بل الملايين
من الاوكرانيين خارج اوكرانيا فهنا اتحدث
عن الجنود فليس لن يكون لديهم قدره بتجديد
قواتهم وهذا ايضا مادفع سؤال ضيفي من
واشنطن الدكتور دوند على ماذا تراغن
واشنطن في الحاق هزيمه بموسكو اقتصاديا
كما ذكرت ضيفتي استطاعت موسكو ان تجد
البديل لهذا الحظر عسكريا تقول موسكو
بانها اثبتت بان اسلحتها استطاعت ان تواجه
كل ما تقدمه او ما يقدمه حلفاء كيف
لكيف حتى الان الحديث عن هجوم مضاد حتى
الان مازال حديث عن امتار في الحديث عن
تقدم وتراجع من قبل هذا الفريق او ذاك
وبالتالي على ماذا تراغن واشنطن في حال
ديمومه هذه
الحرب اولا اعارض زميلتي الروسيه بالنسبه
الى
معلوماتها ووصفها المضلل لهؤلاء الاشخاص
كانهم روس بحسب استفتاء العام
ومذكره بودابيست والكثير من
الاستفتاءات ان هؤلاء الذين يتحدثون روسيا
هم اوكرانيون ويريدون البقاء في اوكرانيا
وليس الانضمام الى روسيا الاتحاديه بغض
النظر عن ما قاله بوتين اما الوضع العسكري
اعتقد ان الجيش الروسي وكما
اسلفتم يلعب لعبه دفاعيه لا يتحرك لا
يبادر الى الاعتداء ليس لديه القدره
القتاليه التي يدعونها من اجل ان ينتقل
الى موقع الهجوم ربما بعد نصف سنه او سنه
قد يكون لديه ذلك لكن الان لا هم يريدون
ان يلعبوا اللعبه الدفاعيه للوقت الحالي
بوتين يعتمد على ان يسم الغرب من
دعم الجهود القتاليه الاوكرانيه هذا افضل
امل
يحدوه من اجل التوصل الى تسويه تكون لصالح
روسيا هل سيحصل ذلك انا اشكك لانه ليس
هناك مؤشر بان غالبيه الدول في ح الاطلسي
او الغرب سوف يخففون من دعم اوكرانيا ضد
الاعتداء الروسي يضاف الى ذلك ما يحصل بعد
هذه التسويه هو ان روسيا سيكون عليها ان
تدفع مقابل جرائم الحرب التي ارتكبتها
تدمير البنى التحتيه قتل المدنيين تحدثهم
عن المصنع النووي هذا كله يعني ان القياده
الروسيه يجب ان تحاسب وليس على سبيل
الصدفه ان نرى الكثير من القاض الروس
متهمين بجرائم حرب
من محكمه الجنايات الدوليه او
غيرها روسيا سوف لن تربح هذه الحرب وانا
لا ارى اي خيار امامها الا ان تترك
اوكرانيا
وشانها وان تساهم في اعاده اعمار ما تسببت
به عمليات الخطف والقتل وتدمير المدارس
والمستشفيات الى ما هنالك هناك مسار طويل
قبل نهايه ذلك
وكما ق قلتم بدون اي مفاجاه لا يمكن للجيش
الروسي ان ينتقل الى موقع الهجوم وبالتالي
يفعل ما يمكنه ان يقوم بها الا وهو
استهداف المدنيين على امل ان يسم الغرب او
يتعب من دعم اوكرانيا شك شكرا لك ادركنا
الوقت ضيفي من واشنطن الدكتور دونالد
جونسون الدبلوماسي الامريكي السابق في
موسكو وكذلك الشكر لضيف من موسكو اولجا
كراسين ياك الاكاديميه والمحلله السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه وكذلك لضيف من عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء باذ
[موسيقى]
الله